hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor and I've been
running a property investment Channel
now for about six years and I've been
full time in property for 14 years and
in this video I want to tell you why I
actually think now in 2023 is one of the
best opportunities to get into property
now some of you who are broke and don't
know anything about the economy will
think Samuel you're crazy you're deluded
but I'm going to give you 10 reasons why
I believe that now is a good time for
you to be buying properties the first
reason is because everybody's scared
right now Warren Buffett who's one of
the richest men in the world says when
everyone's scared when everyone's
getting out that's when you should get
in all the rich people right now are
investing in property they're buying
land and the media are telling you not
to do it so if you're like oh no Samuel
you're deluded now's a bad time you're
probably listening to the media you're
probably listening to the newspapers so
the first reason I think you you should
get it now is because everybody else is
not everybody else is being scared
imagine if there's a market stand and
they're selling fruits and then they get
to a point where they need to get rid of
the fruit that really motivate to sell
the fruit fast and then you're like oh
scary no now go in and get cheap fruit
in the same way when houses are selling
cheap because people are worried about
interest rates because people are
worried about house prices dropping
where people are worried about the
economy and what's happening then Now's
the Time to get in so that's the first
reason the second reason I think you're
getting now is because getting into
property is not just investing in
property it's not just buying a house
and renting it out getting into property
is finding deals flipping them packaging
and selling properties controlling
properties taking rooms and sticking
them on Airbnb getting into property
means getting into property it means
being the property investor and
entrepreneur and I think right now we
need to make money more money the
average salary is about two thousand
three thousand pounds a month after tax
and then after you pay your rent and
your bills what you left with nothing
there's a cost of living crisis so the
second reason I think that you need to
get into property now is because
property is a really good way to make
extra money even if you're not investing
in property you could be packaging and
selling deals trading properties
controlling properties sometimes I just
think how on Earth are people living on
two grand a month right now because the
average rent is a thousand pounds Energy
prices and utility bills have tripled
over the last 12 months
you need right now not to be saving
money not to be being Frugal you need to
be finding ways to 10x your income you
need to be finding ways to earn twenty
thirty thousand pounds a month that's
the solution property lends itself to
you being a property entrepreneur as
well as just a property investor that's
reason number two reason number three if
you invest in property regardless of
what's going to happen over the next six
12 months property is one of the safest
Investments you can invest in it is a
commodity if you own land they're not
building any more land
okay the richest people on the planet
are investing in real estate right now
it's real estate because it's real if
you invest into cryptocurrency Bitcoins
and even businesses I'm not saying
they're bad Investments I invest in
businesses too I've invested in
cryptocurrencies but the thing that
you're buying can disappear if you buy a
business will you invest in a business
that business can crash and burn if you
buy a house even if the house crashes
and burns even if there's world war
three and you lose the house you still
have the land and the land the free
whole land is what holds its value and
right now there's a massive population
of people and the world isn't getting
any bigger so own a piece of Earth own
as much land as you can someone once
said don't wait to buy land buy land and
wait and that's because it always holds
its value look back over the last 10
years 20 years 50 years 100 years
thousand years and see that land has
been the best thing to holding its value
up there with gold and ultimately the
best investment is not property it's
yourself but that's the third reason why
I think you should be buying property
and getting into it in 2023. reason
number four and by the way if you're
enjoying this video do me a favor smash
the like button go ahead and hit that
like button okay reason number four is
because government are actually making
it easier to make money in property the
rich people invest in property and the
rich people make the rules for example
recently they changed submitting
development rules so there's a lot of
properties now that you can do things to
like you can extend you can build at the
side you can take commercial properties
and you can change the use and convert
them into Residential Properties all of
these things you can now do without
getting planning permission that is huge
so while all the poor people are
listening to the media about being
scared and about not getting into
property the rich people are seeing the
new changes seeing the new rules making
the new rules and then taking advantage
of some of these new rules there's a
massive shortage of houses right now in
the UK and the government are making it
easier for developers to develop homes
so go where the tide is going so I think
for that reason I'm in reason number
five I touched on this already the rich
people are doing it when Lloyd's Bank
are telling you not to invest in
property because it's risky look at what
they're doing follow the money if you
can see that Lloyd's back what are they
doing investing aggressively into
even Bill Gates
is investing heavily into Land look at
what the rich people are doing go to the
Sunday Times rich list and look at what
everyone's doing go on company's house
find out what they're owning find out
what they're buying and you'll see Dad
buying property they're buying land so
for you to sit here and say oh Samuel
you're talking nonsense well not only am
I wealthy in doing property and land and
development and real estate but all the
other wealthy people doing am I crazy am
I deluded or maybe is the media deluding
the average person right now next number
six property pays you three times you
get paid once when you buy the house
assuming you buy it at the right price
of course if you buy a house that's
worth 200 000 but you buy it for 160.
you got it 40 000 pounds below market
value which right now there are people
doing because they're motivated to sell
because they're scared straight away you
made forty thousand pounds in what we
call theoretical Equity that's the first
time you get paid next number two you
get paid then when you rent the property
out again assuming you rent it out at
the right price if you rent it out
really low and it's a really high price
the rent might not cover the mortgage
payments so you've got to buy at the
right price and you've got to rent at
the right price maybe rent it out by
splitting it into a HMO on permitted
development rights like we talked about
or maybe rent it out on Short State
let's but you're going to get paid a
monthly rental income and number three
you're gonna get paid when when the
house goes up in value now you might be
thinking but something that's going to
drop maybe well maybe houses are going
to drop I predicted that in a video a
few months ago that this year I think
houses will drop generally if you buy
the wrong house especially but once it
drops what's then going to happen what's
going to happen in 10 years it's going
to go up
house prices on average double in value
every 10 years and every 10 years
because I was saying this 10 years ago
because oh but not this 10 it won't and
it did it did last 10 the 10 before the
10 before the 10 before and of course
this is a general principle she's not a
rule but the principle is the house
prices hold their value over time and
keep going up so you're getting paid
multiple times when earning properties
next Point number seven passive income
is real the biggest myth about passive
income is that passive income doesn't
exist it
and the best vehicle passive income in
my experience because you can make
passive income from vending machines and
e-commerce business but the most passive
of all passive incomes in my opinion is
property is real estate especially
commercial property if you own property
you rent it to commercial tenants like I
do with quite a lot of my properties it
is completely
passive you get in your rent on a
10-year lease every year how many times
you have to work no you don't income
coming in without working most people
work for money they trade their time for
money when you own property and you rent
it out the money just keeps coming in
even if you're asleep it's the best
passive income vehicle I believe in the
world next number eight
I said it
many ways you can write taxes off
through property I mean I'll give you a
couple okay disclaimer I'm not tax uh
professional so I can't give tax advice
so I'm going to touch on it and then you
go do your own research number one how
do rich people not pay taxes let me
explain a rich person sets up a company
and what they do is they push the value
up of that company and then rather than
taking income from the company because
then they're going to pay income tax
they don't do that they borrow money
against the company that's what they do
and what is property really good at well
it's really good at borrowing against it
if you own real estate instead of
selling and paying capital gains tax or
corporation tax instead of just renting
and paying income tax you can borrow
against the property
and that money that you're taken out of
the property you don't pay any tax on
and with that money you can buy more
Properties or you can go on holiday or
whatever you want but I would advise
snowboarding your portfolio so from a
tax perspective also man I mean pensions
I now have a pension but the only sole
purpose of that pension is to invest in
property and you know pay tax again go
do your own research on this and find
out what you can do from a tax
perspective or if you're one of my
students we can sit down together I can
introduce to my team but the tax breaks
in property mean for me
I'm in number nine there's so many
different strategies that you can do
within property you can do lease
optional agreements hmos service
accommodation rent to rent deal
packaging buy refurbish refinance
commercial property property development
commercial to residential like there's
just so many different ways so depending
on your skill set right and depending on
where you are if you've got no money and
you're starting out from scratch and
you're like I don't got any money well
fine you can do deal packaging package
deals and sell them or you can control
properties on rent to rent if you've got
loads of money and you're a bit risky
and you're worried about the market
dropping right buy lands and push the
value up by getting planning permission
and then flip it the pie is so big in
property so do this is now's a bad time
to get into property it's like what are
you talking about do you even know how
to get into property maybe it's a bad
time to buy a house and live in it but
it was always a bad time to buy a house
and live in it because that doesn't give
you any money so the diversifications in
property that you can do make it an
absolute yes for me and lastly number 10
the property Community is just an
amazing supportive uplifting space I've
got a property Community I run you know
property events and communities my
property Academy and the people are so
uplifting and positive I was thinking
recently I was thinking if I ever quit
property which I never would but if I
ever did What Would I miss the most and
it wasn't actually the properties that I
would miss the most it's not even the
money it's the community of people that
are supportive and positive you know
being around good people is so so
important in business and in life for
your own well-being and the amount of
being beautiful people in the property
Community is incredible so if you want
to be part of the property Community if
you want to come and meet with me in
person and meet my team I'd like to
invite you to spend one pound and come
down to the property investors crash
course I'm going to leave a link in the
description and I believe if you know
what you're doing and if you're prepared
to work hard now is the best time ever
to get into property
foreign
[Music]